right it's a third license sorry what's
the purpose of this blockade this block
it's a block here stepping people just
checking driver's licenses and insurance
I know you've been doing that for a
couple of weeks now two weeks a everyone
sorry I'm just checking your driver's
license man what's the purpose of a
camera um because we know exactly why
this is all here is people gonna benefit
of the bike okay we heard ourselves from
the freshmen that they heard there was
gonna be some plantations why this is
set up here
we're asking you to wait for freedom
please if you understand mrs. orange
freedom do you understand that this is
our decedent he was still in territory
here source freedom I don't work like so
how will we just do that and you know
show us some good nature are you doing
we're the only group that's really
publicized out there opposing the
pipelines and blocking pipeline workers
from coming in here so to me when
they're saying northern British Columbia
we can guarantee it is us the
interaction with one of your people was
not appropriate it's not appropriate for
him to stand in front of of the police
and suggest that we can't cross the
bridge or can't cross the public roadway
I informed him what my goal was
this is in effect in tan story I mean
legally it's your right I mean as as the
First Nations people if this is your
territory
to to represent that to voice that to
express that to anybody that wishes to
come into the territory or if they want
to do work in the territory to settle
that matter through the courts people
don't need that to prove that this is
our land it always has been the province
and everybody else needs to prove why
they think they can access our land we
don't trust police because we're
suspicious they your forces would come
in to scope out our layout so that if
there is an injunction you guys will be
better prepared than how you're going to
deal with
clay visits and threatened anybody that
tries to stop you from freely walking
ends gonna get arrested so along with
the flesh fangs and the non-lethal
things they will use lots of
intimidation and getting up in your face
and being really loud it's really loud
and one of the things they do is this
thing it sucks
and so it's good to see what it looks
like if you were to get arrested here
what are you're gonna be charged with
resisting arrest and probably some other
like large amount of conflated charges
that have no legal basis whatsoever my
main takeaway with this blog don't
listen to anything the cops say about
what they're gonna charge you with cuz
it's gonna be a whole bunch of my simple
say you are up on a ladder or up on
something high there's cops trying to
grab your feet and you shake one off of
your foot and you make contact with
their head with your foot you have
assaulted a police officer that's a
felony charge you know that before c-51
throws a major charge is big jail time
now after c-51 it's probably a lot
bigger so I think that c-51 especially
has maybe stopped some newer activists
from getting involved they think that
little charges are going to become big
ones they see the political protests you
can now get trumped-up felony charges
for things like conspiracy but I think
that seasoned activists realized that
the government of canada is going to use
this as their first case so that they
can throw a whole bunch of people in
well this Kevin was first built in 2009
and the reason why it was strategically
put here was because this was the
initial route for Pacific Trails
pipeline and Enbridge so we put the
cabin right here right in the GPS route
of where the pipeline route was proposed
to go for both of those everywhere they
lay that pipe we will no longer have
access to our territory and we use those
territories for berries for medicines
for hunting and viewing their pipeline
route for our territory it's all where
our prime berry picking is on there's so
much at stake here for our people and
they say they developed c-51 for the
purpose of protecting canada's critical
infrastructure projects and what we're
doing here is we're protecting our
critical infrastructure yeah an expert
now so we do order more fish then come
in and take this cat down just from
zenith the RCMP have been going to other
First Nations that have been trying to
defend their lands you see it on the
news all the time where they're kept for
spraying elders and arresting people so
you know it is possible that they would
be and we're here canning fish
are you what are you doing here we're
just on the coastal gas line we're doing
one invasive testing non-invasive work
leads to permits permits leads to
projects that we do not approve of it's
going to destroy our lines and the
company has already been told you don't
have permission to be here so I'm gonna
ask you guys to leave so our crews safe
to be here yeah you gotta leave do I
look like I'm trying to harm you no no
i'm peacefully asking you to leave
because you're trespassing so please get
back in your chopper and they
I am now MOX I'm highest rank in chief
of the Thai you one of the five clans
that were totin on behalf of no mucks
father climb to freedom we asked
permission to come and join you we have
come here to be with you to make sure
you understand you were doing the right
thing beside my site kill for a while
even though we got a lot of verbal
support we didn't get physical support
out here and it means a lot that we have
hereditary Chiefs coming here supporting
what we're doing and backing up what
we've been telling media our hereditary
system is what governs our land
who are you my brave man with Chevron
representing the Pacific Trail pipeline
project we're here today to talk to you
about doing work on your land and
requesting access onto your territory so
that when Soltan people can work and to
see benefits from the project we allow
access us to access the territory here
today we've already said no to these
projects and that no pipelines will come
on our territory and irregardless if
you've got other which you would and
members working for you does that give
you access to exactly these pipeline
projects will wipe out vast tracts of
land that will prevent us from doing our
berry picking or medicines that's what
you'll be wiping out and our salmon is
our staple food you'll be wiping out all
our food sources I don't eat
store-bought meat everything I eat comes
off my land all my medicine I get off
the land I don't go to the doctor and
you're trying to convince us to give up
our way of life so that you can reap the
benefits for governments and investors
and while you're throwing crumbs to some
of the partners that sign them it's just
basically from so what you're telling us
is that you will not allow us access
onto the territory we brought you an
offering we've left some water some
tobacco leaf no thanks we've got clean
water right there that's what we drink
and that's pollution the plastic that
adds to the landfill so you could take
your take your my water cuz we don't
like that
Hey